you know jimmy kimmel headed off for
summer vacation after apologizing for
his racially insensitive actions but it
may be hard for him to relax
with his tv future now cast in doubt
people are talking about me what have
they been saying good things
by the end of the week people will hate
me again
that's my goal apologies are great but
apology should be accompanied
with accountability i don't think it's
enough to say hey i was wrong but those
are my silly immature
days in his apology jimmy writes that
when he performed his blackface sketches
on the man show
in the early 2000s quote i thought of
them as impersonations of celebrities
and nothing more
home alone never seen no flying saucer
himself but if he do that's going to be
a spooky time
the manchester's going good back in 2001
special e.t correspondent regis philbin
spoke to jimmy about his controversial
show politically and career you don't
care whatever whatever comes to your
mind you say
we you're not afraid of anything that's
right kimmel now tells e.t
quote i believe that i have evolved and
i hope that is evident to anyone who
watches my show
but what about the future of jimmy
kimmel live is abc upset with jimmy
kimmel show
they will be eventually i know how this
goes right now we're still in the
honeymoon phase i don't believe that
jimmy kimmel's show should necessarily
be cancelled when things matter to jimmy
kimmel he's used his television platform
he needs to do the same thing now with
his apology and his accountability
it's imperative to do it on the air he
has spoken out about black lives matter
i think he frankly needs to have carl
malone on the late shift author bill
carter who executive produced an
upcoming cnn docu-series about late
night
also weighs in on the embattled host who
is now on vacation
i think it's just postponing the
inevitable i don't doubt the sincerity
of his apology though because i know the
guy
he's really one of the best people that
i've met in covering show business this
isn't the kind of guy he is
and i think he now knows it was a big
mistake he's going to have to address it
on the air when he comes back
he could have used zoom he could have
used his cell phone he could have made a
one-minute apology that they then added
to the top
of the show the landed audience is
really amazingly forgiving
i mean you know obviously the jimmy
fallon thing came up
he apologized it's gone and look at the
david letterman stuff i mean david
letterman's thing was
outrageous so i'm not expecting him to
have a long-term problem with his
audience while i am gone a cavalcade of
very kind and capable people will be
filling in for me i think you're going
to be very happy with them
we're told kimmel is with his family in
idaho he's airing repeats for the next
two weeks
his first fill-in host after that is
anthony anderson
jimmy doesn't go back until september
right around when he's set to host the
emmys
but could that be in jeopardy the actual
hosting of the show
isn't particularly difficult it's all
the nonsense that surrounds it the
comments online
you'll remember in 2018 comedian kevin
hart gave up hosting the oscars after
his past homophobic tweets
emerged causing backlash even though
kevin had previously apologized
regardless academy i'm thankful and
appreciative of the opportunity
some fans are outraged over what they
say is a double standard one tweeted
quote
jimmy kimmel did multiple sketches in
blackface and gets to host the 2020
emmys
huh what we need to do is give jimmy
kimmel an opportunity to be contrite and
to be accountable
but if he's not then he's got to go too
did you guys have fun was that fun
it's interesting that he actually won an
emmy last year for executive producing
the live versions of
creator norman lear's groundbreaking
shows which tackled race relations
humanity hasn't changed from the time we
were doing all the family event
uh jefferson and he understood that
they were controversial and they did we
just didn't have social media back then
maybe if we had social media back then
these shows wouldn't have survived i
don't know
there are many opinions on the cancel
kimmel movement we spoke with let's make
a deal host wayne brady
do you still have to answer for your
sins from 10 20 years ago canceled
culture is real because the power of
social media is real
there are some people who what they've
said and done is so
heinous that of course you got to be
canceled
someone like jimmy kimmel i've watched
him as a fan
and i've been on this show a couple
times he has grown
[Music]